hi everyone
my name is coleman madden and i'm an
engineer with google cloud in new york
focused on asset management in the hedge
fund industry
prior to google has been around 10 years
working in the data engineering space
i'm also here with david lee from
blackrock whom i've been collaborating
with
since early 2019. david over to you
thank you coleman hi my name is david i
work in the financial modeling group
at blackrock the group consists of a
team of engineers
modelers and researchers working
together to develop best-in-class
analytics to clients
today's agenda is as follows i'll first
introduce what we do at blackrock
then present two use cases of how we
generate signals using natural language
processing
on google cloud first i'll talk a little
bit about how we train against returns
to construct a bespoke dictionary to
analyze sentiment for single issuers in
the structured credit
space second i'll talk about knowledge
graphs and entity linking
and about how we trained an entity
linking model
to build a foundation for constructing
knowledge graphs in addition i'll talk
about some use cases for these concepts
coleman will then conclude with
forward-looking views
of how to conduct investment research on
google cloud in the future
i did a team inside fmg called advanced
data analytics
our responsibilities spend engineering
financial modeling and natural language
processing
for data engineering we process data
sets that are terabytes in size
to extract insight by leveraging big
data technologies such as spark
some of our work have been previously
presented at spark summit east
we also leverage managed services
provided by public clouds
our goal is to efficiently deliver
data-driven solutions to our clients
as a team we have a wide range of skills
and provide flexible
end-to-end solutions to streamline
future engineering
the building of financial models and
productionization
our approach to natural language
processing is a little bit more focused
on research
we pay a lot of attention to recent
developments in the applications
of text classification information
extraction
and entity linking in the nlp space
the first use case is classifying text
in the structured credit market
in the past decade or so the leveraged
loans market size has been increasing
also due to private nature of these
investments
publicly available structured data sets
may be common but sparse
taking a bottoms up approach we analyze
credit at the issuer level
we aim to tackle the problem with
feature engineering to add more insight
to the model
which is to look at issuer defaults and
measure probability of default run
issuer
at the beginning of the year the u.s
leveraged loans market was around 1.2
trillion dollars
more than half of that is the u.s
collateralized loan obligations market
which is close to 700 billion in the
past two years
we've seen record issuances of close to
120 billion dollars per year
in 2018 and 2019. this increased market
size
coupled with companies assuming more
debt give rise to additional risk
in the market at the same time risks are
becoming increasingly difficult to
capture
for example environmental changes such
as covid has
significant impacts to competitive
landscape in multiple sectors
such as retail as the political
landscape and regulatory oversight
changes over time
companies are exposed to increased
uncertainty
additionally they're also held to higher
standards
companies are now facing mounting
pressure on environmental
social and governance in order to
address these issues and capture
additional information from alternative
data sets
we turn to natural language processing
we analyze large volumes of textual news
via nlp
to classify text into sentiment scores
as well as other metrics
such as news volume and emotions in
these articles
some of the challenges in predicting
issue are probability of default or pd
over some time horizon r first
it's typically difficult to find
structured data on issuers due to their
private nature
in instances of where data is actually
available it can still be subject to
sparsity
such as pricing data due to these
instruments lacking in liquidity
trying to apply nlp to this problem
available news corpora are typically at
least terabytes in size
and can easily exceed petabytes across
multiple periods
given these we need both persistence and
compute
resources to be flexible whereas they
typically are constrained
in a fixed computation form thus
we need a flexible environment to
iterate and test our ideas so we can
extract
and classify text for predicting
probability of default
let's take a look at the modeling
process here
first we start off with loading the data
then we apply transformations such as
tokenization
stemming named recognition and sometimes
even applying language models to reason
about text in the embedding space
then we align unstructured text with
structured data sets such as returns or
spreads
this step has to be done carefully to
match market open and close times as
well as time zones
and ways to de-duplicate articles that
discuss the exact same thing
once this is done we query the data
stored
and train and evaluate our ideas by
tuning hyper parameters
and finding thresholds to construct an
optimal bespoke sentiment dictionary
then we iteratively roll this dictionary
across time for inference
this process has proven to be quite
straightforward on google cloud
we start off by persisting various
stages of our data to cloud storage
which is a highly available distributed
store that gives us plenty of scratch
areas to test our ideas
then we provision data proc clusters
with gcloud in cloud console
this provides us with an ephemeral
hadoop spark cluster compute cluster
across our large data sets an auto
scaling policy and preemptable machines
are your best friend when managing these
clusters
recent metrics demonstrate that spark 3
performance on kubernetes is catching up
to
yarn this is good news as we can then
potentially switch to spark carburetors
in the future
after that we leverage bigquery to run
analytical workloads
and extract and filter relevant
information
bigquery has similar functions as hive
storing metadata and being on compute
engine
however for bigquery there's no tuning
or configuration involved
it automatically handles your workloads
and produces results quickly
finally we use ai notebooks and cloud
storage as a combination
to iterate over our training and
evaluation cycle
these managed notebooks give us the
flexibility to scale our resources up
and down
through configuration changes
usually operating on premise we need to
be very careful about resource
consumption
as well as capacity planning due to the
multi-tenancy nature of our shared
compute clusters
typically a single etf job that we've
previously done could take up to about
an hour
and we have thousands of these jobs to
run on google cloud
after carefully configuring our setup
we're able to compact that time per
iteration down to two hours for the
entire data set
armed with scalability and flexibility
to change the cluster size as well as
the type of cluster
we can iterate on multiple tests and
focus more of our time on ideation and
modeling
as opposed to worrying about whether
we're consuming too much compute
resources
some lessons we learned during this
exercise spark
the defacto open source big data
processing tool is great for etl and
disk i o intensive jobs
for large scale optimization
calculations not so much
we turn to distributed compute
frameworks such as desk and ray for
parallelizing these optimization tasks
to optimize our runtime or to minimize
our runtime
let's switch gears to our second topic
this one is more exposure in nature and
has received increased
attention in the past few years in the
research community
we explore the applications of entity
linking and knowledge graphs
in the equity space we want to extract
information for the correct securities
moreover we want to track and identify
relationships between entities
so we need entity linking to map text to
an entity in some knowledge base
some examples of applications are
extracting and analyzing supply chain
impacts to companies revenues and
expenses think of foxconn
manufacturing iphones additionally
samsung is a supplier of screens for
apple
therefore understanding correlation of
performance between companies due to
their shared dependencies in the same
suppliers
help us better build equity risk models
similarly we can analyze corporate
structures such as ownership and
subsidiaries
and here we define ownership kind of
loosely
we analyzed this to gain insight how
performance of one company
affects another lastly
we were talking about esg before
creating models
and measuring corporate governance can
be aided with calculating the diversity
of boards
experience and expertise of board
members and how a member's track record
may affect the company of performance
that they sit on
on the right hand side you can see a
snapshot of a partial knowledge graph
it shows the ownership relations of
blackrock as well as google
and the two companies are connected
through alphabet which is the parent
company of google
and in which blackrock owns shares
to construct a knowledge graph a
fundamental step is of the problem
of entity linking or el here's a simple
example
given a sentence larry whom we know is
the chairman is ceo of blackrock
said at the beginning of the year that
blackrock would place sustainability at
the center of investment approach at the
firm
in this example it's relatively easy for
humans to understand that larry refers
to lawrence d fink
the ceo of blackrock and blackrock as
the investment management company
for a model the difficulty lies in
training a system that can correctly
link textbands
to entities that live in some knowledge
base such as wikipedia
the objective of el is as following
given a piece of text
recognize disambiguate and link entities
to an entry defined in some knowledge
base
we use birt as a language model where it
was developed by google ai in 2018
and a knowledge base that's a mix of
wikipedia and other sources in this case
we use lotiago
our task is to detect mentions and
disambiguate entities
looking at this problem we need to
provision resources that can scale with
our workload
namely to leverage gpus for training of
large neural networks
the productionization process of these
models have typically been complex
and we show how we can use google cloud
to achieve this
looking at the following high-level
architecture
we can see that connecting blackrock and
google networks through interconnect
and keeping the traffic between the data
centers is a good way to start
with a remote interpreter on a virtual
machine instance on compute
engine we're able to test different
types of configurations of gpus and tpus
and to them for training we then set up
a request server
to run evaluation on a local machine and
then forward the port
lastly we deploy our models through
tensorflow serving
to expose the entity linking model to
clients through an api
through cloud endpoints this end-to-end
approach
allowed us to quickly iterate and train
our models and minimize the deployment
time of our models to production
next i'll hand it over to coleman to
give a forward-looking view of
investment research
at google cloud thanks david so david
covered two great use cases
where his team have been leveraging gcp
at blackrock and i wanted to talk a
little bit more broadly
on how the investment industry is
partnering with google's cloud
i don't think it's any secret that the
buy side is becoming increasingly
dependent on data and ai to power
investment decisions
and you'll see that by looking at some
of the statistics here on the right hand
side of the slide
at google cloud we believe this aligns
really well with our powerful analytics
platform
and the ai research coming out of google
brain which we provide to our customers
to our style platform
why don't we start by looking at a
typical investment decision flow for a
buy side firm
so firstly formulate an investment idea
source data to prove out that
hypothesis generate signals from the
data
construct the portfolio back test the
portfolio
present the findings and determine a
capital allocation from an investment
committee
before moving into production the blue
box
highlights the stages of process we feel
are a great fit for google cloud
so why run investment research on google
cloud firstly
to provide the ability for investing
teams to spin up projects quickly
and react to events in the market in an
agile fashion
two streamline the onboarding of new
data sets from commercial data vendors
such as refinitive and cme group to our
data marketplace
three burst compute workloads into the
cloud and eliminate resource contention
from on-prem compute firms or get access
to the latest ai research to our apis
and manage services
and five orchestrate your ml workflows
with state-of-the-art devops
and ml ops platform so how do we do
all this on google cloud
here's a high level architecture of how
firms are running investment research on
gcp
we start off by looking at the blue box
this is our data acquisition project
where the data engineering teams onboard
various data sets such as market
portfolio
news data etc and we look at the green
yellow boxes below
this is where the research teams are
using their tools to access the data
sets above
we understand there's often a wall
between different investment teams
and we can implement this using our
identity and access management tools
while still allowing access to shared
resources such as tick history
so let's dive into the gcb products
let's sit behind these boxes
in the data acquisition project we can
ingest streaming the
data via our pops up message queue our
lan files on google cloud storage
trigger load jobs into bigquery or no
ops data warehouse
data flow and their proc are available
for etl we're also seeing a lot of
customers
moving to an elt architecture where they
load the data as quickly as possible
and then use the power of bigquery to
actually do that transformation using
anti-sequel
the data marketplace allows data
publishers aggregators
to share their data sets with financial
firms without the need for any etl
this is extremely valuable as data sets
are often in the petabytes
you may have seen we just announced
bigquery omni which will
enable firms to query the data on aws
or azure from a single interface without
any cross-cloud movement of our copies
of data
we push the compute to the data
in the research projects quantitative
researchers can run simulations on hpc
clusters
with hundreds of thousands of cores
custom vms that perfect the ratio of
course memory
if your workload can handle preemptions
and needs to run for less than 24
hours preemptable vms allow you to do
this at an 80
discount we just launched confidential
vms which allow you to
encrypt data during processing and even
when it's in memory
so moving to the right our cloud ai
platform allows quantitative researchers
to create ai notebooks
with the latest tensorflow pytorch and
psych learning images
on cpus gpus or tpus and pull this
these data sets straight into pandas
data frames
automl allows you to create machine
learning models for natural language
structured data translation without
having to write any code
these models can be trained to
understand terminology that is specific
to the financial services industry
our document ai solutions enable you to
process complex financial filings and
earnings reports
with cutting edge nlp and transfer
learning technologies
ai pipelines is built on top of qflo and
tfx
and provides an mlaps solution
to evaluate train and deploy machine
learning models to production
these models can be shared with other
research teams
through ai hub one really important
thing to note here is that this is all
deployed
by infrastructure as code uh using
something like deployment manager
or terraform scripts
so how do you get started so step one
you want to get the cloud foundations in
place understand your requirements
around
networking security access management
wrap these up in infrastructure as code
and feed these into your project
creation pipeline
secondly you want to understand the
process for onboarding new data sets
and build a data acquisition pipeline to
automate this
thirdly understand what tools your
researchers need and automate the
deployment of these tools
along with the connectivity they need to
access the data required to run their
experiments
we want to make life easier for everyone
thank you for coming along to our talk
today
please add any questions to dory or feel
free to reach out to me or david
directly